The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
So welcome to 6.172.
My name is Charles
Leiserson, and I am one
of the two lecturers this term.
The other is
Professor Julian Shun.
We're both in EECS and in CSAIL
on the 7th floor of the Gates
Building.
If you don't know it, you are
in Performance Engineering
of Software Systems, so
if you found yourself
in the wrong place,
now's the time to exit.
I want to start today by
talking a little bit about why
we do performance
engineering, and then I'll
do a little bit
of administration,
and then sort of dive into
sort of a case study that
will give you a good sense
of some of the things
that we're going to
do during the term.
I put the administration
in the middle,
because it's like, if from me
telling you about the course
you don't want to
do the course, then
it's like, why should you listen
to the administration, right?
It's like--
So let's just dive right in, OK?
So the first thing
to always understand
whenever you're
doing something is
a perspective on what
matters in what you're doing.
So the whole term, we're going
to do software performance
engineering.
And so this is kind
of interesting,
because it turns out that
performance is usually
not at the top of what people
are interested in when they're
building software.
OK?
What are some of the
things that are more
important than performance?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Deadlines.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Deadlines.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Cost.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Cost.
AUDIENCE: Correctness.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Correctness.
AUDIENCE: Extensibility.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Extensibility.
Yeah, maybe we
could go on and on.
And I think that you
folks could probably
make a pretty long list.
I made a short list
of all the kinds
of things that are more
important than performance.
So then, if programmers
are so willing to sacrifice
performance for
these properties,
why do we study performance?
OK?
So this is kind of a bit of a
paradox and a bit of a puzzle.
Why do you study
something that clearly
isn't at the top
of the list of what
most people care about when
they're developing software?
I think the answer to
that is that performance
is the currency of computing.
OK?
You use performance to buy
these other properties.
So you'll say
something like, gee,
I want to make it
easy to program,
and so therefore I'm willing
to sacrifice some performance
to make something
easy to program.
I'm willing to sacrifice
some performance to make sure
that my system is secure.
OK?
And all those things come out
of your performance budget.
And clearly if performance
degrades too far,
your stuff becomes unusable.
OK?
When I talk with people,
with programmers, and I say--
you know, people are fond
of saying, ah, performance.
Oh, you do performance?
Performance doesn't matter.
I never think about it.
Then I talk with people
who use computers,
and I ask, what's your main
complaint about the computing
systems you use?
Answer?
Too slow.
[CHUCKLES] OK?
So it's interesting,
whether you're the producer
or whatever.
But the real answer is that
performance is like currency.
It's something you spend.
If you look-- you
know, would I rather
have $100 or a gallon of water?
Well, water is
indispensable to life.
There are circumstances,
certainly,
where I would prefer
to have the water.
OK?
Than $100.
But in our modern
society, I can buy
water for much less than $100.
OK?
So even though water
is essential to life
and far more important than
money, money is a currency,
and so I prefer to have the
money because I can just
buy the things I need.
And that's the same kind
of analogy of performance.
It has no intrinsic value,
but it contributes to things.
You can use it to buy
things that you care about
like usability or
testability or what have you.
OK?
Now, in the early
days of computing,
software performance
engineering was common
because machine
resources were limited.
If you look at these
machines from 1964 to 1977--
I mean, look at how many bytes
they have on them, right?
In '64, there is a computer
with 524 kilobytes.
OK?
That was a big
machine back then.
That's kilobytes.
That's not megabytes,
that's not gigabytes.
That's kilobytes.
OK?
And many programs would strain
the machine resources, OK?
The clock rate for that
machine was 33 kilohertz.
What's a typical
clock rate today?
AUDIENCE: 4 gigahertz.
CHARLES LEISERSON: About what?
CHARLES LEISERSON: 4 gigahertz,
3 gigahertz, 2 gigahertz,
somewhere up there.
Yeah, somewhere
in that range, OK?
And here they were
operating with kilohertz.
So many programs would not fit
without intense performance
engineering.
And one of the things, also--
there's a lot of sayings
that came out of that era.
Donald Knuth, who's a Turing
Award winner, absolutely
fabulous computer
scientist in all respects,
wrote, "Premature optimization
is the root of all evil."
And I invite you,
by the way, to look
that quote up because it's
actually taken out of context.
OK?
So trying to optimize stuff
too early he was worried about.
OK?
Bill Wulf, who designed
the BLISS language
and worked on the
PDP-11 and such,
said, "More computing
sins are committed
in the name of efficiency
without necessarily achieving
it than for any other
single reason, including
blind stupidity."
OK?
And Michael Jackson
said, "The first rule
of program optimization--
don't do it.
Second rule of
program optimization,
for experts only--
don't do it yet."
[CHUCKLES]
OK?
So everybody warning
away, because when
you start trying to
make things fast,
your code becomes unreadable.
OK?
Making code that is
readable and fast-- now
that's where the art
is, and hopefully we'll
learn a little bit
about doing that.
OK?
And indeed, there
was no real point
in working too
hard on performance
engineering for many years.
If you look at
technology scaling
and you look at how
many transistors
are on various processor
designs, up until about 2004,
we had Moore's law
in full throttle, OK?
With chip densities
doubling every two years.
And really quite amazing.
And along with that, as
they shrunk the dimensions
of chips--
because by miniaturization--
the clock speed would go up
correspondingly, as well.
And so, if you found
something was too slow,
wait a couple of years.
OK?
Wait a couple of years.
It'll be faster.
OK?
And so, you know,
if you were going
to do something with software
and make your software ugly,
there wasn't a real
good payoff compared
to just simply waiting around.
And in that era,
there was something
called Dennard scaling,
which, as things shrunk,
allowed the clock speeds
to get larger, basically
by reducing power.
You could reduce power and
still keep everything fast,
and we'll talk about
that in a minute.
So if you look at what
happened to from 1977 to 2004--
here are Apple computers
with similar price tags,
and you can see the clock
rate really just skyrocketed.
1 megahertz, 400 megahertz,
1.8 gigahertz, OK?
And the data paths went
from 8 bits to 30 to 64.
The memory,
correspondingly, grows.
Cost?
Approximately the same.
And that's the legacy
from Moore's law
and the tremendous advances
in semiconductor technology.
And so, until 2004,
Moore's law and the scaling
of clock frequency,
so-called Dennard scaling,
was essentially a printing
press for the currency
of performance.
OK?
You didn't have to do anything.
You just made the
hardware go faster.
Very easy.
And all that came to an end--
well, some of it
came to an end--
in 2004 when clock
speeds plateaued.
OK?
So if you look at
this, around 2005,
you can see all the speeds--
we hit, you know,
2 to 4 gigahertz,
and we have not been able
to make chips go faster
than that in any
practical way since then.
But the densities
have kept going great.
Now, the reason that the
clock speed flattened
was because of power density.
And this is a slide from
Intel from that era,
looking at the growth
of power density.
And what they were
projecting was
that the junction temperatures
of the transistors on the chip,
if they just keep scaling the
way they had been scaling,
would start to
approach, first of all,
the temperature of a
nuclear reactor, then
the temperature of
a rocket nozzle,
and then the sun's surface.
OK?
So that we're not going
to build little technology
that cools that very well.
And even if you could
solve it for a little bit,
the writing was on the wall.
We cannot scale clock
frequencies any more.
The reason for that is that,
originally, clock frequency
was scaled assuming
that most of the power
was dynamic power,
which was going
when you switched the circuit.
And what happened as we kept
reducing that and reducing
that is, something that used
to be in the noise, namely
the leakage
currents, OK, started
to become significant
to the point where--
now, today-- the
dynamic power is
far less of a concern
than the static power
from just the circuit
sitting there leaking,
and when you miniaturize,
you can't stop that effect
from happening.
So what did the vendors
do in 2004 and 2005
and since is, they
said, oh, gosh, we've
got all these
transistors to use,
but we can't use the transistors
to make stuff run faster.
So what they did is, they
introduced parallelism
in the form of
multicore processors.
They put more than one
processing core in a chip.
And to scale performance,
they would, you know,
have multiple cores, and each
generation of Moore's law
now was potentially doubling
the number of cores.
And so if you look at what
happened for processor cores,
you see that around
2004, 2005, we started
to get multiple processing
cores per chip, to the extent
that today, it's
basically impossible
to find a single-core chip
for a laptop or a workstation
or whatever.
Everything is multicore.
You can't buy just one.
You have to buy a
parallel processor.
And so the impact of
that was that performance
was no longer free.
You couldn't just
speed up the hardware.
Now if you wanted to
use that potential,
you had to do
parallel programming,
and that's not something
that anybody in the industry
really had done.
So today, there are
a lot of other things
that happened in that
intervening time.
We got vector units as
common parts of our machines;
we got GPUs; we got
steeper cache hierarchies;
we have configurable logic on
some machines; and so forth.
And now it's up to the
software to adapt to it.
And so, although we
don't want to have
to deal with
performance, today you
have to deal with performance.
And in your lifetimes,
you will have
to deal with
performance in software
if you're going to have
effective software.
OK?
You can see what
happened, also--
this is a study
that we did looking
at software bugs in a variety
of open-source projects
where they're mentioning
the word "performance."
And you can see that in 2004,
the numbers start going up.
You know, some of
them-- it's not
as convincing for
some things as others,
but generally there's
a trend of, after 2004,
people started worrying
more about performance.
If you look at software
developer jobs,
as of around early, mid-2000s--
the 2000 "oh oh's,"
I guess, OK--
you see once again the mention
of "performance" in jobs
is going up.
And anecdotally,
I can tell you, I
had one student who came
to me after the spring,
after he'd taken
6.172, and he said,
you know, I went and I
applied for five jobs.
And every job asked me,
at every job interview,
they asked me a
question I couldn't
have answered if I hadn't taken
6.172, and I got five offers.
OK?
And when I compared
those offers,
they tended to be 20% to
30% larger than people
who are just web monkeys.
OK?
So anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
That's not to say that
you should necessarily
take this class, OK?
But I just want to point out
that what we're going to learn
is going to be interesting
from a practical point of view,
i.e., your futures.
OK?
As well as theoretical
points of view
and technical points of view.
OK?
So modern processors
are really complicated,
and the big question
is, how do we
write software to use that
modern hardware efficiently?
OK?
I want to give you an example
of performance engineering
of a very well-studied problem,
namely matrix multiplication.
Who has never seen this problem?
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
OK, so we got some jokers
in the class, I can see.
OK.
So, you know, it takes
n cubed operations,
because you're basically
computing n squared
dot products.
OK?
So essentially, if you add up
the total number of operations,
it's about 2n cubed because
there is essentially
a multiply and an add
for every pair of terms
that need to be accumulated.
OK?
So it's basically 2n cubed.
We're going to
look at it assuming
for simplicity that our n
is an exact power of 2, OK?
Now, the machine that
we're going to look at
is going to be one of
the ones that you'll
have access to in AWS.
OK?
It's a compute-optimized
machine,
which has a Haswell
microachitecture running
at 2.9 gigahertz.
There are 2 processor chips
for each of these machines
and 9 processing cores per
chip, so a total of 18 cores.
So that's the amount
of parallel processing.
It does two-way hyperthreading,
which we're actually
going to not deal a lot with.
Hyperthreading gives you a
little bit more performance,
but it also makes it really
hard to measure things,
so generally we will
turn off hyperthreading.
But the performance
that you get tends
to be correlated with what
you get when you hyperthread.
For floating-point
unit there, it
is capable of doing 8
double-precision precision
operations.
That's 64-bit
floating-point operations,
including a fused-multiply-add
per core, per cycle.
OK?
So that's a vector unit.
So basically, each
of these 18 cores
can do 8 double-precision
operations,
including a fused-multiply-add,
which is actually 2 operations.
OK?
The way that they
count these things, OK?
It has a cache-line
size of 64 bytes.
The icache is 32 kilobytes,
which is 8-way set associative.
We'll talk about
some of these things.
If you don't know all
the terms, it's OK.
We're going to cover most
of these terms later on.
It's got a dcache
of the same size.
It's got an L2-cache
of 256 kilobytes,
and it's got an
L3-cache or what's
sometimes called an
LLC, Last-Level Cache,
of 25 megabytes.
And then it's got 60
gigabytes of DRAM.
So this is a
honking big machine.
OK?
This is like-- you can get
things to sing on this, OK?
If you look at the
peak performance,
it's the clock speed
times 2 processor
chips times 9 processing
cores per chip, each capable
of, if you can use both
the multiply and the add,
16 floating-point
operations, and that goes out
to just short of teraflop, OK?
836 gigaflops.
So that's a lot of power, OK?
That's a lot of power.
These are fun
machines, actually, OK?
Especially when we get into
things like the game-playing AI
and stuff that we do
for the fourth project.
You'll see.
They're really fun.
You can have a lot
of compute, OK?
Now here's the basic code.
This is the full code
for Python for doing
matrix multiplication.
Now, generally, in Python,
you wouldn't use this code
because you just call a
library subroutine that
does matrix multiplication.
But sometimes you
have a problem.
I'm going to illustrate
with matrix multiplication,
but sometimes you have
a problem for which
you have to write the code.
And I want to give you an idea
of what kind of performance
you get out of Python, OK?
In addition, somebody has to
write-- if there is a library
routine, somebody
had to write it,
and that person was a
performance engineer,
because they wrote it to
be as fast as possible.
And so this will give you
an idea of what you can
do to make code run fast, OK?
So when you run this code--
so you can see that
the start time--
you know, before the
triply-nested loop--
right here, before the
triply-nested loop,
we take a time
measurement, and then we
take another time
measurement at the end,
and then we print
the difference.
And then that's just this
classic triply-nested loop
for matrix multiplication.
And so, when you run this,
how long is this run for,
you think?
Any guesses?
Let's see.
How about-- let's do this.
It runs for 6 microseconds.
Who thinks 6 microseconds?
How about 6 milliseconds?
How about-- 6 milliseconds.
How about 6 seconds?
How about 6 minutes?
OK.
How about 6 hours?
[LAUGHTER]
How about 6 days?
OK.
Of course, it's important
to know what size it is.
It's 4,096 by 4,096, as
it shows in the code, OK?
And those of you
who didn't vote--
wake up.
Let's get active.
This is active learning.
Put yourself out there, OK?
It doesn't matter whether
you're right or wrong.
There'll be a bunch of people
who got the right answer,
but they have no idea why.
[LAUGHTER]
OK?
So it turns out, it takes
about 21,000 seconds,
which is about 6 hours.
OK?
Amazing.
Is this fast?
AUDIENCE: (SARCASTICALLY) Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, right.
Duh, right?
Is this fast?
No.
You know, how do we tell
whether this is fast or not?
OK?
You know, what should we
expect from our machine?
So let's do a
back-of-the-envelope
calculation of--
[LAUGHTER]
--of how many
operations there are
and how fast we ought
to be able to do it.
We just went through
and said what
are all the parameters
of the machine.
So there are 2n cubed operations
that need to be performed.
We're not doing Strassen's
algorithm or anything
like that.
We're just doing a straight
triply-nested loop.
So that's 2 to the 37
floating point operations, OK?
The running time
is 21,000 seconds,
so that says that we're getting
about 6.25 megaflops out
of our machine when
we run that code, OK?
Just by dividing it out, how
many floating-point operations
per second do we get?
We take the number of operations
divided by the time, OK?
The peak, as you recall,
was about 836 gigaflops, OK?
And we're getting
6.25 megaflops, OK?
So we're getting about
0.00075% of peak, OK?
This is not fast.
OK?
So let's do something
really simple.
Let's code it in Java
rather than Python, OK?
So we take just that loop.
The code is almost the same, OK?
Just the triply-nested loop.
We run it in Java, OK?
And the running time
now, it turns out,
is about just under
3,000 seconds,
which is about 46 minutes.
The same code.
Python, Java, OK?
We got almost a 9 times
speedup just simply
coding it in a
different language, OK?
Well, let's try C.
That's the language we're
going to be using here.
What happens when
you code it in C?
It's exactly the same thing, OK?
We're going to use the
Clang/LLVM 5.0 compiler.
I believe we're using 6.0
this term, is that right?
Yeah.
OK, I should have rerun these
numbers for 6.0, but I didn't.
So now, it's basically
1,100 seconds,
which is about 19 minutes,
so we got, then, about--
it's twice as fast as Java
and about 18 times faster
than Python, OK?
So here's where we stand so far.
OK?
We have the running time of
these various things, OK?
And the relative speedup
is how much faster it
is than the previous row,
and the absolute speedup is
how it is compared
to the first row,
and now we're managing to
get, now, 0.014% of peak.
So we're still slow,
but before we go and try
to optimize it further--
like, why is Python
so slow and C so fast?
Does anybody know?
AUDIENCE: Python is
interpreted, so it has to--
so there's a C
program that basically
parses Python pycode
instructions, which
takes up most of the time.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK.
That's kind of on
the right track.
Anybody else have any--
articulate a little bit
why Python is so slow?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you write,
like, multiplying and add,
those aren't the only
instructions Python's doing.
It's doing lots
of code for, like,
going through Python objects
and integers and blah-blah-blah.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, yeah.
OK, good.
So the big reason why Python
is slow and C is so fast
is that Python is interpreted
and C is compiled directly
to machine code.
And Java is somewhere
in the middle
because Java is compiled
to bytecode, which is then
interpreted and then
just-in-time compiled
into machine codes.
So let me talk a little
bit about these things.
So interpreters, such as in
Python, are versatile but slow.
It's one of these
things where they said,
we're going to take
some of our performance
and use it to make
a more flexible,
easier-to-program environment.
OK?
The interpreter basically
reads, interprets,
and performs each program
statement and then
updates the machine state.
So it's not just-- it's actually
going through and, each time,
reading your code,
figuring out what it does,
and then implementing it.
So there's like all
this overhead compared
to just doing its operations.
So interpreters can easily
support high-level programming
features, and they can do things
like dynamic code alteration
and so forth at the
cost of performance.
So that, you know, typically
the cycle for an interpreter
is, you read the next statement,
you interpret the statement.
You then perform the
statement, and then
you update the state
of the machine,
and then you fetch
the next instruction.
OK?
And you're going
through that each time,
and that's done in software.
OK?
When you have things
compiled to machine code,
it goes through a
similar thing, but it's
highly optimized just for the
things that machines are done.
OK?
And so when you compile,
you're able to take advantage
of the hardware and interpreter
of machine instructions,
and that's much, much lower
overhead than the big software
overhead you get with Python.
Now, JIT is somewhere in the
middle, what's used in Java.
JIT compilers can recover
some of the performance,
and in fact it did a pretty
good job in this case.
The idea is, when the
code is first executed,
it's interpreted, and
then the runtime system
keeps track of how often
the various pieces of code
are executed.
And whenever it finds that
there's some piece of code
that it's executing
frequently, it then
calls the compiler to
compile that piece of code,
and then subsequent to that,
it runs the compiled code.
So it tries to get the big
advantage of performance
by only compiling the
things that are necessary--
you know, for
which it's actually
going to pay off to
invoke the compiler to do.
OK?
So anyway, so that's
the big difference
with those kinds of things.
One of the reasons we don't
use Python in this class
is because the performance
model is hard to figure out.
OK?
C is much closer to the metal,
much closer to the silicon, OK?
And so it's much easier
to figure out what's
going on in that context.
OK?
But we will have a
guest lecture that we're
going to talk about
performance in managed
languages like
Python, so it's not
that we're going to
ignore the topic.
But we will learn how to
do performance engineering
in a place where
it's easier to do it.
OK?
Now, one of the things that
a good compiler will do is--
you know, once you get to--
let's say we have
the C version, which
is where we're going
to move from this point
because that's the
fastest we got so far--
is, it turns out
that you can change
the order of loops
in this program
without affecting
the correctness.
OK?
So here we went--
you know, for i, for j,
for k, do the update.
OK?
We could otherwise do-- we
could do, for i, for k, for j,
do the update, and it computes
exactly the same thing.
Or we could do, for k, for
j, for i, do the updates.
OK?
So we can change the
order without affecting
the correctness, OK?
And so do you think the order of
loops matters for performance?
Duh.
You know, this is like
this leading question.
Yeah?
Question?
AUDIENCE: Maybe for
cache localities.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
OK.
And you're exactly right.
Cache locality is what it is.
So when we do that, we get--
the loop order affects the
running time by a factor of 18.
Whoa.
Just by switching the order.
OK?
What's going on there?
What's going on?
So we're going to talk about
this in more depth, so I'm just
going to fly through
this, because this is just
sort of showing you the kinds
of considerations that you do.
So in hardware, each
processor reads and writes
main memory in contiguous
blocks called cache lines.
OK?
Previously accessed
cache lines are
stored in a small
memory called cache
that sits near the processor.
When the processor
accesses something,
if it's in the
cache, you get a hit.
That's very cheap, OK, and fast.
If you miss, you have to go
out to either a deeper level
cache or all the way
out to main memory.
That is much, much
slower, and we'll
talk about that kind of thing.
So what happens for
this matrix problem is,
the matrices are laid out in
memory in row-major order.
That means you take--
you know, you have a
two-dimensional matrix.
It's laid out in
the linear order
of the addresses of memory
by essentially taking row 1,
and then, after row 1, stick row
2, and after that, stick row 3,
and so forth, and unfolding it.
There's another order that
things could have been laid
out-- in fact, they
are in Fortran--
which is called
column-major order.
OK?
So it turns out C and Fortran
operate in different orders.
OK?
And it turns out it
affects performance,
which way it does it.
So let's just take a look at
the access pattern for order
i, j, k.
OK?
So what we're doing is, once
we figure out what i and what j
is, we're going to go
through and cycle through k.
And as we cycle
through k, OK, C i, j
stays the same for everything.
We get for that excellent
spatial locality
because we're just
accessing the same location.
Every single time, it's
going to be in cache.
It's always going to be there.
It's going to be
fast to access C.
For A, what happens is, we
go through in a linear order,
and we get good
spatial locality.
But for B, it's going
through columns,
and those points are
distributed far away in memory,
so the processor is going
to be bringing in 64 bytes
to operate on a
particular datum.
OK?
And then it's ignoring 7 of
the 8 floating-point words
on that cache line and
going to the next one.
So it's wasting
an awful lot, OK?
So this one has good
spatial locality
in that it's all adjacent
and you would use the cache
lines effectively.
This one, you're going
4,096 elements apart.
It's got poor
spatial locality, OK?
And that's for this one.
So then if we look at the
different other ones--
this one, the order i, k, j--
it turns out you get good
spatial locality for both C
and B and excellent for A. OK?
And if you look at
even another one,
you don't get nearly as
good as the other ones,
so there's a whole
range of things.
OK?
This one, you're doing
optimally badly in both, OK?
And so you can just
measure the different ones,
and it turns out that you can
use a tool to figure this out.
And the tool that we'll be
using is called Cachegrind.
And it's one of the
Valgrind suites of caches.
And what it'll do
is, it will tell you
what the miss rates are for
the various pieces of code.
OK?
And you'll learn how to use
that tool and figure out,
oh, look at that.
We have a high miss rate
for some and not for others,
so that may be why my
code is running slowly.
OK?
So when you pick the
best one of those,
OK, we then got a relative
speedup of about 6 and 1/2.
So what other simple
changes can we try?
There's actually a
collection of things
that we could do that don't
even have us touching the code.
What else could we
do, for people who've
played with compilers and such?
Hint, hint.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could
change the compiler flags.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
change the compiler flags, OK?
So Clang, which is the
compiler that we'll be using,
provides a collection of
optimization switches,
and you can specify a
switch to the compiler
to ask it to optimize.
So you do minus O,
and then a number.
And 0, if you look at the
documentation, it says,
"Do not optimize."
1 says, "Optimize."
2 says, "Optimize even more."
3 says, "Optimize yet more."
OK?
In this case, it turns out that
even though it optimized more
in O3, it turns out O2
was a better setting.
OK?
This is one of these cases.
It doesn't happen all the time.
Usually, O3 does better
than O2, but in this case O2
actually optimized
better than O3,
because the optimizations
are to some extent heuristic.
OK?
And there are also other
kinds of optimization.
You can have it do
profile-guided optimization,
where you look at what the
performance was and feed that
back into the code,
and then the compiler
can be smarter about
how it optimizes.
And there are a variety
of other things.
So with this simple technology,
choosing a good optimization
flag-- in this case, O2--
we got for free, basically,
a factor of 3.25, OK?
Without having to do
much work at all, OK?
And now we're actually
starting to approach
1% of peak performance.
We've got point 0.3% of
peak performance, OK?
So what's causing
the low performance?
Why aren't we getting
most of the performance
out of this machine?
Why do you think?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We're not
using all the cores.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
we're not using all the cores.
So far we're using
just one core,
and how many cores do we have?
AUDIENCE: 18.
CHARLES LEISERSON: 18, right?
18 cores.
Ah!
18 cores just sitting
there, 17 sitting
idle, while we are
trying to optimize one.
OK.
So multicore.
So we have 9 cores per chip,
and there are 2 of these chips
in our test machine.
So we're running on just one
of them, so let's use them all.
To do that, we're going to
use the Cilk infrastructure,
and in particular,
we can use what's
called a parallel loop, which
in Cilk, you'd call cilk_for,
and so you just relay that
outer loop-- for example,
in this case, you say
cilk_for, it says,
do all those
iterations in parallel.
The compiler and runtime system
are free to schedule them
and so forth.
OK?
And we could also do it
for the inner loop, OK?
And it turns out you can't
also do it for the middle loop,
if you think about it.
OK?
So I'll let you do that is
a little bit of a homework
problem-- why can't I just do
a cilk_for of the inner loop?
OK?
So the question is, which
parallel version works best?
So we can parallel the i loop,
we can parallel the j loop,
and we can do i and j together.
You can't do k just
with a parallel loop
and expect to get
the right thing.
OK?
And that's this one.
So if you look--
wow!
What a spread of
running times, right?
OK?
If I parallelize the just the
i loop, it's 3.18 seconds,
and if I parallelize the j
loop, it actually slows down,
I think, right?
And then, if I do both
i and j, it's still bad.
I just want to do
the outer loop there.
This has to do, it turns out,
with scheduling overhead,
and we'll learn about
scheduling overhead
and how you predict
that and such.
So the rule of thumb here
is, parallelize outer loops
rather than inner loops, OK?
And so when we do
parallel loops,
we get an almost 18x
speedup on 18 cores, OK?
So let me assure
you, not all code
is that easy to parallelize.
OK?
But this one happens to be.
So now we're up to, what,
about just over 5% of peak.
OK?
So where are we
losing time here?
OK, why are we getting just 5%?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So another area of the
parallelism that [INAUDIBLE]..
So we could, for example,
vectorize the multiplication.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yep.
Good.
So that's one, and
there's one other
that we're not using
very effectively.
OK.
That's one, and those
are the two optimizations
we're going to do to get
a really good code here.
So what's the other one?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The multiply
and add operation.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
That's actually related
to the same question, OK?
But there's another completely
different source of opportunity
here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We could also do a lot
better on our handling of cache
misses.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
OK, we can actually manage
the cache misses better.
OK?
So let's go back
to hardware caches,
and let's restructure
the computation
to reuse data in the
cache as much as possible.
Because cache misses are
slow, and hits are fast.
And try to make the
most of the cache
by reusing the data
that's already there.
OK?
So let's just take a look.
Suppose that we're going to
just compute one row of C, OK?
So we go through one row of
C. That's going to take us--
since it's a 4,096-long
vector there,
that's going to basically be
4,096 writes that we're going
to do.
OK?
And we're going to get some
spatial locality there,
which is good, but
we're basically
doing-- the processor's
doing 4,096 writes.
Now, to compute that row, I
need to access 4,096 reads
from A, OK?
And I need all of B, OK?
Because I go each
column of B as I'm
going through to fully
compute C. Do people see that?
OK.
So I need-- to just
compute one row of C,
I need to access one row
of A and all of B. OK?
Because the first element of
C needs the whole first column
of B. The second element of C
needs the whole second column
of B. Once again, don't
worry if you don't fully
understand this,
because right now I'm
just ripping through
this at high speed.
We're going to go into this in
much more depth in the class,
and there'll be plenty of
time to master this stuff.
But the main thing
to understand is,
you're going through
all of B, then
I want to compute
another row of C.
I'm going to do the same thing.
I'm going to go through
one row of A and all of B
again, so that when I'm
done we do about 16 million,
17 million memory
accesses total.
OK?
That's a lot of memory access.
So what if, instead
of doing that,
I do things in blocks, OK?
So what if I want to compute
a 64 by 64 block of C
rather than a row of C?
So let's take a look
at what happens there.
So remember, by the
way, this number--
16, 17 million, OK?
Because we're going
to compare with it.
OK?
So what about to
compute a block?
So if I look at a block,
that is going to take--
64 by 64 also takes 4,096
writes to C. Same number, OK?
But now I have to
do about 200,000
reads from A because I need
to access all those rows.
OK?
And then for B, I need to
access 64 columns of B, OK?
And that's another
262,000 reads from B, OK?
Which ends up being half a
million memory accesses total.
OK?
So I end up doing way
fewer accesses, OK,
if those blocks will
fit in my cache.
OK?
So I do much less to compute
the same size footprint
if I compute a block rather
than computing a row.
OK?
Much more efficient.
And that's a scheme
called tiling,
and so if you do tiled matrix
multiplication, what you do
is you bust your matrices
into, let's say, 64
by 64 submatrices,
and then you do
two levels of matrix multiply.
You do an outer level of
multiplying of the blocks using
the same algorithm, and
then when you hit the inner,
to do a 64 by 64
matrix multiply,
I then do another
three-nested loops.
So you end up with
6 nested loops.
OK?
And so you're basically
busting it like this.
And there's a tuning
parameter, of course,
which is, you know, how
big do I make my tile size?
You know, if it's s by s,
what should I do at the leaves
there?
Should it be 64?
Should it be 128?
What number should I use there?
How do we find the right value
of s, this tuning parameter?
OK?
Ideas of how we might find it?
AUDIENCE: You could figure out
how much there is in the cache.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
You could do that.
You might get a number,
but who knows what else
is going on in the cache
while you're doing this.
AUDIENCE: Just test
a bunch of them.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
test a bunch of them.
Experiment!
OK?
Try them!
See which one gives
you good numbers.
And when you do
that, it turns out
that 32 gives you the
best performance, OK,
for this particular problem.
OK?
So you can block it, and
then you can get faster,
and when you do that, that
gave us a speedup of about 1.7.
OK?
So we're now up to--
what?
We're almost 10% of peak, OK?
And the other thing is
that if you use Cachegrind
or a similar tool,
you can figure out
how many cache references
there are and so forth,
and you can see
that, in fact, it's
dropped quite considerably when
you do the tiling versus just
the straight parallel loops.
OK?
So once again, you can use tools
to help you figure this out
and to understand the
cause of what's going on.
Well, it turns
out that our chips
don't have just one cache.
They've got three
levels of caches.
OK?
There's L1-cache, OK?
And there's data
and instructions,
so we're thinking
about data here,
for the data for the matrix.
And it's got an L2-cache,
which is also private
to the processor, and
then a shared L3-cache,
and then you go
out to the DRAM--
you also can go to your
neighboring processors
and such.
OK?
And they're of different sizes.
You can see they grow in size--
32 kilobytes, 256
kilobytes, to 25 megabytes,
to main memory, which
is 60 gigabytes.
So what you can do is, if you
want to do two-level tiling,
OK, you can have two
tuning parameters, s and t.
And now you get to do--
you can't do binary search
to find it, unfortunately,
because it's multi-dimensional.
You kind of have to
do it exhaustively.
And when you do that,
you end up with--
[LAUGHTER]
--with 9 nested loops, OK?
But of course, we don't
really want to do that.
We have three levels
of caching, OK?
Can anybody figure out
the inductive number?
For three levels of caching,
how many levels of tiling
do we have to do?
This is a gimme, right?
AUDIENCE: 12.
CHARLES LEISERSON: 12!
Good, 12, OK?
Yeah, you then do 12.
And man, you know, when I say
the code gets ugly when you
start making things go fast.
OK?
Right?
This is like, ughhh!
[LAUGHTER]
OK?
OK, but it turns
out there's a trick.
You can tile for
every power of 2
simultaneously by just solving
the problem recursively.
So the idea is that you
do divide and conquer.
You divide each of the matrices
into 4 submatrices, OK?
And then, if you look at the
calculations you need to do,
you have to solve 8
subproblems of half the size,
and then do an addition.
OK?
And so you have
8 multiplications
of size n over 2 by n over 2 and
1 addition of n by n matrices,
and that gives you your answer.
But then, of course,
what you going to do
is solve each of
those recursively, OK?
And that's going to
give you, essentially,
the same type of performance.
Here's the code.
I don't expect that
you understand this,
but we've written this
using in parallel,
because it turns out you can
do 4 of them in parallel.
And the Cilk spawn here says,
go and do this subroutine, which
is basically a subproblem, and
then, while you're doing that,
you're allowed to go and execute
the next statement-- which
you'll do another spawn and
another spawn and finally this.
And then this
statement says, ah,
but don't start the
next phase until you
finish the first phase.
OK?
And we'll learn
about this stuff.
OK, when we do that,
we get a running time
of about 93 seconds, which
is about 50 times slower
than the last version.
We're using cache much
better, but it turns out,
you know, nothing is free,
nothing is easy, typically,
in performance engineering.
You have to be clever.
What happened here?
Why did this get worse,
even though-- it turns out,
if you actually look
at the caching numbers,
you're getting
great hits on cache.
I mean, very few cache
misses, lots of hits on cache,
but we're still slower.
Why do you suppose that is?
Let me get someone--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: Overhead to start
functions and [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, the overhead
to the start of the function,
and in particular the place
that it matters is at the
leaves of the computation.
OK?
So what we do is, we have
a very small base case.
We're doing this overhead all
the way down to n equals 1.
So there's a function
call overhead even when
you're multiplying 1 by 1.
So hey, let's pick a threshold,
and below that threshold,
let's just use a standard good
algorithm for that threshold.
And if we're above that, we'll
do divide and conquer, OK?
So what we do is we call--
if we're less than the
threshold, we call a base case,
and the base case looks very
much like just ordinary matrix
multiply.
OK?
And so, when you do that,
you can once again look
to see what's the best
value for the base case,
and it turns out in this
case, I guess, it's 64.
OK?
We get down to 1.95 seconds.
I didn't do the base case
of 1, because I tried that,
and that was the one that
gave us terrible performance.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Sorry.
32-- oh, yeah.
32 is even better.
1.3.
Good, yeah, so we picked 32.
I think I even-- oh,
I didn't highlight it.
OK.
I should have highlighted
that on the slide.
So then, when we do that, we
now are getting 12% of peak.
OK?
And if you count up how
many cache misses we have,
you can see that--
here's the data cache for
L1, and with parallel divide
and conquer it's the
lowest, but also now so
is the last-level caching.
OK?
And then the total number of
references is small, as well.
So divide and conquer turns
out to be a big win here.
OK?
Now the other thing that we
mentioned, which was we're
not using the vector hardware.
All of these things have vectors
that we can operate on, OK?
They have vector hardware that
process data in what's called
SIMD fashion, which means
Single-Instruction stream,
Multiple-Data.
That means you give
one instruction,
and it does operations
on a vector, OK?
And as we mentioned, we
have 8 floating-point units
per core, of which we can also
do a fused-multiply-add, OK?
So each vector register
holds multiple words.
I believe in the machine we're
using this term, it's 4 words.
I think so.
OK?
But it's important when you
use these-- you can't just
use them willy-nilly.
You have to operate on the data
as one chunk of vector data.
You can't, you
know, have this lane
of the vector unit doing one
thing and a different lane
doing something else.
They all have to be doing
essentially the same thing,
the only difference being
the indexing of memory.
OK?
So when you do that--
so already we've actually
been taking advantage of it.
But you can produce a
vectorization report by asking
for that, and the system will
tell you what kinds of things
are being vectorized, which
things are being vectorized,
which aren't.
And we'll talk about
how you vectorize things
that the compiler doesn't
want to vectorize.
OK?
And in particular, most machines
don't support the newest sets
of vector instructions,
so the compiler
uses vector instructions
conservatively by default.
So if you're compiling
for a particular machine,
you can say, use that
particular machine.
And here's some of the
vectorization flags.
You can say, use the AVX
instructions if you have AVX.
You can use AVX2.
You can use the
fused-multiply-add vector
instructions.
You can give a
string that tells you
the architecture that
you're running on,
on that special thing.
And you can say, well, use
whatever machine I'm currently
compiling on, OK,
and it'll figure out
which architecture is that.
OK?
Now, floating-point numbers,
as we'll talk about,
turn out to have some
undesirable properties,
like they're not associative,
so if you do A times B
times C, how you parenthesize
that can give you
two different numbers.
And so if you give a
specification of a code,
typically, the compiler
will not change
the order of associativity
because it says,
I want to get exactly
the same result.
But you can give
it a flag called
fast math, minus ffast-math,
which will allow it
to do that kind of reordering.
OK?
If it's not important
to you, then it
will be the same as the
default ordering, OK?
And when you use that--
and particularly using
architecture native
and fast math, we actually get
about double the performance
out of vectorization,
just having
the compiler vectorize it.
OK?
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Are the data types
in our matrix, are they 32-bit?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
They're 64-bit.
Yep.
These days, 64-bit
is pretty standard.
They call that double precision,
but it's pretty standard.
Unless you're doing AI
applications, in which case
you may want to do
lower-precision arithmetic.
AUDIENCE: So float and
double are both the same?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
No, float is 32, OK?
So generally, people who are
doing serious linear algebra
calculations use 64 bits.
But actually sometimes
they can use less,
and then you can
get more performance
if you discover
you can use fewer
bits in your representation.
We'll talk about that, too.
OK?
So last thing that
we're going to do
is, you can actually use
the instructions, the vector
instructions,
yourself rather than
rely on the compiler to do it.
And there's a whole manual
of intrinsic instructions
that you can call from C that
allow you to do, you know,
the specific vector instructions
that you might want to do it.
So the compiler doesn't
have to figure that out.
And you can also use some
more insights to do things
like-- you can do
preprocessing, and you
can transpose the matrices,
which turns out to help,
and do data alignment.
And there's a lot of other
things using clever algorithms
for the base case, OK?
And you do more
performance engineering.
You think about you're
doing, you code, and then
you run, run, run
to test, and that's
one nice reason to have the
cloud, because you can do tests
in parallel.
So it takes you less time to
do your tests in terms of your,
you know, sitting around time
when you're doing something.
You say, oh, I want
to do 10 tests.
Let's spin up 10 machines and do
all the tests at the same time.
When you do that--
and the main one we're
getting out of this
is the AVX intrinsics--
we get up to 0.41
of peak, so 41% of peak, and
get about 50,000 speedup.
OK?
And it turns out
that's where we quit.
OK?
And the reason is
because we beat
Intel's professionally
engineered Math Kernel
Library at that point.
[LAUGHTER]
OK?
You know, a good
question is, why
aren't we getting all of peak?
And you know, I invite you to
try to figure that out, OK?
It turns out,
though, Intel MKL is
better than what we did because
we assumed it was a power of 2.
Intel doesn't assume
that it's a power of 2,
and they're more robust,
although we win on the 496
by 496 matrices, they win
on other sizes of matrices,
so it's not all things.
But the end of the story
is, what have we done?
We have just done a
factor of 50,000, OK?
If you looked at the gas
economy, OK, of a jumbo jet
and getting the
kind of performance
that we just got in terms
of miles per gallon,
you would be able to run a jumbo
jet on a little Vespa scooter
or whatever type of
scooter that is, OK?
That's how much we've
been able to do it.
You generally--
let me just caution
you-- won't see the magnitude
of a performance improvement
that we obtained for
matrix multiplication.
OK?
That turns out to be one where--
it's a really good example
because it's so dramatic.
But we will see some
substantial numbers,
and in particular
in 6.172 you'll
learn how to print this
currency of performance
all by yourself so that
you don't have to take
somebody else's library.
You can, you know, say, oh,
no, I'm an engineer of that.
Let me mention one other thing.
In this course, we're going to
focus on multicore computing.
We are not, in particular,
going to be doing GPUs
or file systems or
network performance.
In the real world, those
are hugely important, OK?
What we found, however,
is that it's better
to learn a particular
domain, and in particular,
this particular domain--
people who master multicore
performance engineering,
in fact, go on to do
these other things
and are really good at it, OK?
Because you've learned the
sort of the core, the basis,
the foundation--